[Music]
these days rosewater is something of a
beauty trend but it's been used for
centuries it's thought to have
originated in what is now iran and it's
a cultural staple there to this day
[Music]
this great big story is inspired by
genesis
[Music]
for the world's best rose water you have
to go to the hemser district in iran
there you will find mo sin who comes
from a long line of rose water makers
foreign
[Music]
and there's a reason most sins family
has been making rose water here for
centuries
[Music]
those special conditions like the soil
temperature sea level and gentle winds
makes the hemser district ideal for
growing roses
a lot of roses
[Music]
a
[Music]
the flowers are boiled with water in
large copper pots where condensation is
collected
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
unfortunately times are changing for the
rose water industry there aren't as many
family farms as there once was but for
some like mohsin and his family making
rose water is more than a business
[Music]
a